weaken or destroy them and I would
really like to know if it is a lack of
serious effort or if it is just
incompetent failure I think it's both of
those things and I think there's a bit
of a fiddle going on too
so you said words to the effect that
Islamic state poses a danger there isn't
a country in the world to which it
doesn't pose a strategic danger I mean I
said looking at the nation to whom it
does yes yes which happens to be most
most powerful nations in the world right
I don't think it does you know
shock horror I don't think Islamic state
is in any way as dangerous to this
nation for example than the IRA was it's
unbelievably incompetent its followers
are very easily wrapped up they're
nowhere near the level of terrorists
skills and the IRA was only ever a
tactical problem he was a horrible thing
Omar was a grotesque murder spree 7/7
was a hideous thing but it's not going
to stop the trains running it's not
going to shut down our power grid it
isn't a strategic threat you could argue
that in the medium to long term
if Islamic state ideology was to take
root among the Islamic populations in
Europe that then there could be a
strategic threat but you'd be having to
extrapolate from microscopic beginnings
and show a degree of contempt that I'm
sure you and I would not have to the
vulnerability of the overwhelming
majority of Muslims and Christian
fundamentalist if you were to take
political rhetoric at face value it
would appear that people are much more
worried about the potential for British
Muslims to be radicalized than they are
about the potential for Christian
fundamentalism yeah they are but let it
be and that is deliberate on the part of
Islamic state that's exactly how they
want people to be thinking they want to
and they have been very successful in
going back to the days of al Qaeda
completely distorting the intelligent
terms of the political debate so even if
you could take 9/11 yes it was a
spectacular attack it was a sort of act
of war but then the the the foolish
response from the
West right across the world was to treat
this as a war on terror notice that
nobody uses that term anymore because
even the nitwit realized the cupid yeah
because you're walking straight into
what Osama bin Laden wanted to do a
little man in a cave can suddenly
provoke this massive clash of
civilizations in the apse there was no
clash of civilizations but he was able
to get the West a deliverer one and that
so I'm so but I just want to bring you
back to the fact that even if if I agree
with your argument that actually we're
not that worried about is and it's not
that I'm not that worried everybody else
is professionally extremely well point
is that as a nation and as a you know as
an alliance we are conducting airstrikes
America is using drone attacks we are
committing resources we are deploying to
try and ostensibly defeat the Islamic
state we're involved in Syria we are
affected by the way to fall out of the
conflict through the refugee crisis
through the destabilization in the
region I really want to know if we are
trying to solve the problem and if so
why looking specifically our is doesn't
seem to be working and is it because
it's not actually that much of a
priority or is it because something's
just going wrong or is it because we
will underestimate Islamic state and I
think we often portray them as this kind
of cartoon character medieval mutters
with Stone Age views and guns in pursuit
of virgins which I I often wonder
whether that that trivializes the level
of threat that they actually pose right
well I don't agree that they pose a
strategic threat but I do agree
absolutely that it would be very silly
wait and see Islamic state as a bunch of
swivel-eyed kind of Mardis lunatics they
a lot of their behavior may appear to be
terrifyingly mad but the bad news is it
is terrifyingly well thought through so
they follow for example in terms of
their use of public savagery that is a
doctrine that they are following in a
113 page document written by an
anonymous author in 2004 called
something to the effect of the use of
savagery in pursuit of dominance by the
Ummah it is an absolutely and it lays
out in detail you know what you need to
do is get 26 innocent people
cut their heads off and put their heads
on poles and show them in the main
street and then put it on the internet
and put it on the television that has
been absolutely deliberate so they have
been able to completely dominate the
propaganda space you know no
organization ever including the
superpowers have managed to generate so
much free publicity for relatively tiny
inverse vests potentially Donald Trump
drawn from the same doctrine who knows
but it is available at West Point
there may be the the so they are very
and that and that is an approach they
take to everything they do so they do
incredibly thorough bureaucratic studies
on the efficacy of their water projects
they punish corruption very rapidly they
deliver justice very fast and arguably
very equitably unless it relates to
their own particularly foreign fighters
who they seem to need to keep sweeter
than than others of course it's violent
it's grotesque a lot of it is genocide
all but it is meticulous and a lot of
people don't realize that this
meticulous approach to the use of terror
intelligence and administration tying
them all tying violence as the thread
amusing it as the thread to tie together
highly efficient administration comes
from the bath party of Saddam Hussein
which is a party that was pan-arab and a
bubble secular which is now dominating
the leadership of is yes the sub
leadership in is did the people who were
part of the resistance against the
American occupation in Iraq were a lot
of them of artists officers very very
highly accomplished combat people forget
these people fought it for a decade
against Iran these are not cowardly
incompetent people they're very highly
motivated very very highly trained
particularly in in the sort of the
landscape that they're operating in they
joined the insurgency it was sort of
then crashed and so on but but those
skills can metastasize very rapidly when
you create the right environment
ironically what was now seeing to some
degree is attempted defections by
ideologues
who are very uncomfortable with the
presence of the Baathist perhaps even
uncomfortable than
repulsed by the level of violence or the
level of disrespect that they're often
shown so they're starting to see these
guys as an elite that is separate from
themselves within Islamic state they've
been defections around Aleppo a big
Dutch contingent trying to defect a lot
of them were executed and that I think
is an area that will be exploited by
intelligence organizations what what
intelligence organizations always want
to do a part and find out what the enemy
is up to is quartz cause friction within
these groups and I think that is an
opportunity to create friction but that
but that doesn't answer your other
question is is why haven't they been
dealt with given the scale of the their
enemies I mean they kind of find someone
who isn't an enemy of his master I mean
the presence of senior Baathists you
know from the era of Saddam Hussein
doesn't explain how they have been able
to resist so effectively right so the
attempts that have been made to weaken
them do you get the impressions though
that the attempts are sincere well it's
a good question you know during the
whole debate about air strikes that was
you know the the question was it kind of
tokenism the need for Parliament to be
seen to be doing something with it
actually sincere belief that we could
make any real impact if it's annexed ape
in my view of his lamech State posed the
threat that the Western leadership and
indeed the Russians say they that it
poses to global security all the rest of
it they would have been obliterated a
long time ago the reason they haven't
been obliterated long time ago is I
think that people are kind of putting
the obliteration of so-called Islamic
state somewhat on the back burner while
they try to figure out what an earth to
do about Bashar al-assad in Damascus and
they're fearful that the in the West was
fearful that if he was knocked over that
that space would be entirely filled by
something like so-called Islamic state
and the chaos would flop follow and they
seen the failures
you